(instrumental music)
- 35 women, really folks!
How many more do we need?
35 allegations.
Let's understand
this number, okay?
That's like if
Bill Cosby drugged
and raped every
single U.S. President
from George Washington
to John F. Kennedy!
(laughter and applause)
Mhmm, it's true!
But Grover Cleveland
was asking for it!
(mumbles)
Baaaaah!
(applause)
Instead of saying that he was
ready for the twirly mustache!
- And there's not much
upside to claiming
that you were victimized by one
of the most powerful
people in Hollywood.
- When have we seen
rape victims come up?
Like, where is the
big, I haven't seen
someone get a reality
show to make a famous
- Yeah, you don't
get a book, right.
- pretend rape victim.
- There's no merchandise
opportunity in this.
- There's no
merchandise opportunity.
(audience laughs)
- First, he doesn't
believe the women,
then he doesn't believe me.
- I didn't say...!
(audience shouts)
(applause)
- [Man] Alright,
enough of y'all.
- Here's what we're gonna do!
You get the card, and for your
opinion about women you get
all this green tea, okay?
(mumbles)
(laughter)
Hey America, Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me, I
do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.